once home to the printing presses for
The Daily Express and Daily Telegraph
the West Ferry printers site in London's
Docklands is at the center of cash for
favors allegations which have forced the
housing secretary Robert Genrich to
publish details of his contacts with the
developer former Express newspapers
owner Richard Desmond after they met at
a Tory dinner the disclosure that mr.
Desmond gave the Conservative Party
12,000 pounds two weeks after mr.
generic approved the billion pound
scheme to build 1,500 flats on the 15
acre site prompted labour to demand in a
Commons debate publication of all
correspondence texts and emails about
the Development Minister said he'd
released all relevant information these
documents show contrary to the wild
accusations and the baseless innuendo
propagated by the Honourable gentleman
opposite and restated today in a series
of totally inaccurate statements and
comments this was a decision taken with
an open mind on the merits of the case
Mr genrich's as the dinner was the first
time he'd met mr. Desmond who had
invited him on a site visit then sent
him a number of text messages and tried
to contact him by phone on reflection he
would not have exchanged numbers he
wrote but in a cordial text to mr.
Desmond on the evening of the dinner
November the 18th last year mr.
genrich's said good to spend time with
you tonight Richard see you again soon I
hope mr. Desmond replied thanks Robert I
really appreciate your text will call
your office tomorrow to arrange very
best but by December 23rd mr. Desmond
appeared impatient texting we've got to
get the approval before January the 14th
otherwise payments of 45 million pounds
to Tower Hamlets meaning we have to stop
and reduce social housing and on January
the 9th this year one housing department
of
she mailed another saying on timing my
understanding is that the Secretary of
State is or was insistent that decision
issued this week
ie tomorrow as next week the viability
of the scheme is impacted by a change in
the London regime far from closing down
the conversation with mr. Desmond
mr. generic initiated a conversation
with him the very next morning by text
and it's clear from the documents that
mr. generic rushed through this decision
on the 14th of January January
deliberately so you could help mr.
Desmond avoid paying 30 to 50 million
pounds in tax but the government is
closing ranks around mr. generic over
the West Ferry scheme cabinet secretary
Sir Mark said well says the Prime
Minister considers the matter is closed
John Craig Sky News